tutti i ragazzi benvenute questo video
sono famigie non urlo perché siamo nel
centro di milano sono colmi va bocciato
questa ripreso in primo piano del babbo
e niente stiamo camminando in centro
tanto non so neanche troppo freddo si
dice anche dove stiamo andando che
stiamo andando
si tuffa troppe domande stiamo andando
allora il presente dice la festa del
papà è la disney vuole darmi una mano
per farti un regalo per la festa del
papà un regalo a me sei a dirlo sì
perché la c'è scritto disney di
portamento di votino aspetta che
dobbiamo entrare prego prego le apro la
porta signore prego esattamente per
prego prego completo a tutti lui noi non
c'è lui non c'è io fai finta che non ci
siano
e comunque se i ragazzi possano mio
padre al disney store aspetta 30 entra
aspetto che queste persone non ci sono
non le guardare vieni qua allora visto
che a lui piace tanto star wars
io ho deciso di fare una cosa molto
carina ho deciso di sfidarlo a una home
ci mettiamo a un match di spade laser di
star wars
se tu vinci ti regalo la strada di star
wars
scegli la spada tu a scegliere in questo
momento è quella che vuoi è quella lì è
perfetto ecco questa qui che tp a queste
questa è mia tu prendi quella verde
prendi cura vero grazie se io ti
colpiscono il punto è mio
se tu mi colpisce con l'asp ha
ovviamente senza il cartone ma lo
leviamo se tu mi colpisce con la spada
hai vinto tu
e se vinco me la tengo se vincita da
dire quindi ragazzi che possiamo
cominciare
niente più inizia a scartare le spalle
grosse che io mi preparo il preparato
fisicamente e spiritualmente
allora io siccome
c'è una sorpresina che mio padre che io
nello scorso video perché io ho già
fatto un qualcosa del genere no e quindi
io ho una veste adeguata per tutto
questo perché io sono il baricentro
[Musica]
avrai vita facile con papi geni
serissimo
[Musica]
oh ma l'arbitro o
arbitro
[Musica]
sì però io non ci vedo è così vabbè ho
adesso le spade
si prova una roba c'è i punti
come funziona il padre tifate tifate è
stata cosa ti fa tre chi fa ora ma un
attimo c'erano specie
colpito è eni aveva musica cene
[Musica]
quel film
certo che si accanisce troppo quello
giovane cerca finisce troppo no no no
accettare va bene cene senza l'altro
arrivare mazzate forti ci mancherebbe
parte più anziano ma che farle che non è
più bravo anche come attore quello
ragazze due spanne sopra
per farlo il vecchio che si vede cartone
che studiano
[Musica]
ma di non fare furtivo macao
poi
[Musica]
affondare ma io sono tuo padre
no aspetta c'è qualcosa che non va c'è
un aspetto che centra per i nodi giusto
adesso ecco chi è così perfetto
io sono tuo padre
[Musica]
era così buona buona
perfetto il vincitore della famiglia
gobbi geni ma cos'è marcos lavitola ma
shop
ma lasciamo pen ma che senso ha che cosa
ha fatto
e giusto ma cosa giusta 33 per l'arbitro
è giusto che anche la ventura l'ha
pescato per strada ma certamente più
fumate lui padre 3 fatto tre belle
ragazze questo era il video per la festa
del papà ringrazio mio papà che ha
partecipato a questo video e siccome
valorosamente ha vinto questa partita ti
regalo la spada giusta e mi prendo
questa sì proprio un sacco meritata
quindi ragazzi speriamo che video vi sia
piaciuto come si è piaciuto essere un
momento mi piace anche ai vari social
che come nei video c'è l'arbitro che
volevamo ringraziare quest'arbitro
fantastico eri molto meglio con questa
cosa quindi ragazzi auguri al papa che
che la festa del papà e noi ci vediamo
un po
vale tre punti